when you were in high school you decided
to take an acting class that was in
senior year now I didn't do it yeah
because you're living out in L.A Richard
Dreyfuss one of the greatest actors of
all time he was in that class Albert
Brooks one of the most brilliant
comedians of all time are in your class
with you taking and acting right right
did you see signs of Brilliance with
those guys or is it early on everybody
just sort of a schlub no no you did see
signs of Brilliance particularly Albert
Albert was like a comedy Prodigy he
could at age 16 could make my father and
you know a seasoned professionals laugh
when you say make your father would he
come over the house and like kind of do
like an informal stand up in front of
your father yes he did one time he did a
routine that put my father away he plays
this is at your house this is at my
house he said I'm the greatest escape
artist of all time
and what he did was I I'm not he took
like a napkin and he says okay tie my
hands up and we started to and he just
draped the napkin over it was not even
tied it was just like drape he put a
napkin in his mouth and he went behind a
curtain right and he says now he's going
to try to get out I mean literally just
walk out and from behind the curtain you
hear I can't breathe I can't breathe and
and my dad was gone I mean it was just
your dad say hey I gotta sign this guy
up for something
um I you know he just couldn't believe
that he was to a Joey Bishop one time
Joey Larry Bishop was also a friend he
was in the class too right and uh Joey
Bishop's son Larry who you later teamed
up with for a little while he goes into
Joey Bishop had a den that had plaques
all Awards you know a shrine to him best
Jew I ever met you know I mean every
conceivable award and Albert again at
age 15 16 comes in the Rings and he Joe
is showing it around to somebody showing
the the room and Albert comes he says
miss the bishop they want all these
things back by noon
get out of here Albert get out of here
but the pressure in your life when you
have friends like Albert Brooks and your
father's Carl Reiner and Joey Bishop and
Larry bit right yeah
that like is is there room for a normal
childhood or is everyone always trying
to outdo everyone like whenever I'm
around comedians funny people even funny
guys from Radio I don't want to be on
all the time and I felt like you had to
be on in a way to compete for your
father's attention there was that there
was that and I you know I couldn't
compete and that's certainly not even
with Albert I mean when Albert and
anytime Albert got in a group and I
don't care who was in there I mean it
could have been Robin Williams Billy
Crystal I don't care who was in that
group when Albert started that was it
wow it was the most brilliant even
around Billy Chris around anybody they
all quieted down it was like okay let's
Albert go wow and I and he would go at
parties and people would go crazy and I
remember one time he finished his
routine people are screaming screaming
and then he walks he left leaves the
party you know 20 minutes later uh the
hostess the party comes up to me says
Albert's on the phone he wants to talk
to you I get on the phone I said Albert
what's up he says rob you got to do me a
favor I said what he said I left my keys
in the apartment I can't I can't come
back can you get the keys and bring them
to me he had been walking around for 20
minutes no because he had finished the
pressure couldn't come back
foreign